well the amygdala is a small region of
the brain it's in what's called the
temporal lobe of the brain if we divide
the cerebral hemispheres into the four
major lobes occipital temporal parietal
and frontal it's in the temporal lobe
which is under the temporal bone which
is behind your ear and the amygdala
would be located in a point at a point
where a line that goes through your eye
and through your ear in a set intersect
in your brain so imagine like someone
has shot an arrow through your eye and
want another one into your ear where
those two come together would be roughly
where it is and on both sides of the
brain of course because most structure
in fact all structures are bilateral in
that sense so it's a you know it's
sometimes referred to as an almond or an
almond shaped structure which is a bit
of a misnomer because there's one part
of it that's almond shaped and that
caught the attention of early anatomist
and so they named this almond shaped
structure or the amygdala but as the
amygdala began to be defined more
broadly it includes a lot of structures
other than that little almond shaped
piece it's most commonly associated with
fear although that's not it's only
function it's it's most heavily studied
function and the reason for that is that
it's much easier to study fear than
other emotions of things that are or bad
have more weight than things that are
good in a sense and you can put off
eating drinking sex whatever for an
indefinite amount of time but you have
to respond to danger immediately you
know you don't find great novels about
happy subject it's always about you know
the bad stuff and it's sometimes said
that there's this negative bias and
emotion which is that most research on
emotion is about the negative stuff but
the fact is that negative stuff turns
out to be the most important for
survival in a sense in terms of
immediacy and having to respond to
so some of the key interconnections of
the amygdala and these connections
actually define what it does in the
sense at least with respect to fear the
amygdala gets sensory information
directly from the various sensory
systems that process the external world
so be the visual system the auditory
system a factory touch pain and so forth
all of these kind of come together or
converge in the amygdala and then the
amygdala connects on the output side
with all the systems involved in
emotional reactivity so when you
encounter sudden danger you might freeze
your blood pressure and heart rate began
to rise stress hormones are released all
these things happen as a result of
outputs of the amygdala so the amygdala
you can think of as kind of this this
circle with one input coming in being
the or the input coming in being a
sensory flow of sensory information from
the external world then outputs being
connections to systems involved in
controlling the responses so but we have
to expand those inputs so it's getting
not just one sensory input but all
sensory inputs so each sensory system is
coming in and it doesn't stop there
because in addition to getting
information from sensory systems it also
gets information from higher order
systems like the prefrontal cortex and
higher order Association areas involved
in various kinds of integrative
activities in the cortex
what it does is a function of what
connections it has so because it has
connections with all these sensory
systems it can take in information from
the environment of a variety of types
and use that information and so if you
know if a sound and the in the external
world occurs right before something
painful happens you associate that sound
with the painful event and that sound
will then later trigger a protective
defense response but if the sound occurs
just before food when you're hungry then
the sound will be associated with with
that kind of a positive or repetitive
event and so what the amygdala is doing
is forming associations between random
or neutral external stimuli and the
kinds of reinforcing events that will
stamp in those experiences in a stronger
way so it's it's creating these what's
called Pavlovian associations you know
stimulus 1 plus stimulus 2 if one of
those is in a biologically significant
stimulus then the other one will require
some kind of biological significance
itself whether it's positive or negative
and that information can then be used
and this is sort of what I think you're
referring to in terms of adaptive
behavior so that csus relationship or
say a sound food relationship can then
be used to guide instrumental behavior
which is goal-directed behavior so if in
the past you've obtained food at a
certain location the stimuli that are
proximal to that location service
conditions stimuli and you know are
reinforcing to you because they're close
to the actual goal and they take you
towards the goal same thing happens with
the vs. stimulate the it's just that it
works in the opposite way